it's been months since nineteen went
grocery shopping for dinner
this smells good it reminds me of home
I'll use it later we use it a lot in our
cuisine
Nadine hasn't been able to cook once
since she fled the war in Syria for
Europe cooking is not possible in
refugee homes EULA Schroeder from Berlin
joined forces with some friends to set
about changing that they founded a
project called kitchen on the run
it gives refugees like Nadine a chance
to invite friends over and cook for them
I haven't cooked a meal for six months
so I'm thrilled to have a chance to make
dinner for others in her home cooking
for others is part of my culture Sally
Adam Yoko
she'll be cooking in a mobile transport
container on the grounds of this church
in deuce book you'll and her team raised
150 thousand euros to turn it into a
kitchen and travel with it across Europe
since it took to the road in March 1200
refugees and their guests have eaten
dinner in it but tonight is different
and yulish water is excited tonight is
special because it's Ramadan so the
refugees and people from Duisburg who
joined them tonight will be breaking the
fast
hi I'm Nadine and her friends from a
nearby refugee home are in charge today
after everyone's introduced themselves
it's down to business everyone has a job
to do from cleaning up to chopping
vegetables language barriers aren't a
problem
that was the SMS pizanno sign today will
be special because lots of refugees are
coming who haven't been able to cook for
a long time and they'll be able to cook
their own food and also share it with
others share their culture with others
it means a lot to people by giving
friendless garbage to feed of us
personnels the mobile kitchen is criss
crossing the whole of europe
it reached Duisburg after stopovers in
body in Italy at Marseilles in France
the next stops are in the Netherlands
and Sweden the tables have been set
outside dinner is ready just before
sunset it's a perfect evening to break
fast we're so happy we can cook for our
friends we've been so busy with the
preparations we didn't have time to feel
hungry cm evident nadine and her fellow
chefs have been right in 30 guests they
believe that food is the way to the
heart if that's true
eula shrewder and the kitchen on the run
are spreading a lot of love all across
europe